what is something that everyone looks
stupid doing like you just look like an
idiot every time you do that yet you
still do it comedy yeah stand-up comedy
you're holding a microphone and you're
just talking to strangers so Dom imagine
my grandfather saw my God doing skits
doing skits he's like you're getting
paid it is the job Oh looking at their
own Instagram story yes you should treat
that as masturbation masturbation yeah
you look dumb doing it I think the end
of masturbation is like the exact
opposite of how we like to hold
ourselves in general a society what door
ISA yeah dogs look stupid doing it they
invented it I know they did invent who
ended missionary he looks stupider than
humans doing it thing we do it better
than him I thought about this a lot okay
anal sighs really yeah nobody look
nobody looks like they're having I mean
it's it's pleasurable for people where I
understand it just doesn't look I think
initial assertion yeah it's always like
Oh sitting on a high stool or a low
chair yeah it's dumb these are all I
just know all these are all fat guy
problems using the elliptical machine
yeah that's dumb yeah that's dumb that's
not real no one has ever looked cool no
right but it's all the rage now yeah
because reality sucks so much yeah we
just want to live in a they said
porn in VR is all the or the big thing
now yeah oh you know what everybody
looks stupid doing is looking for their
glasses yeah they're like yeah and
they're always on the head but it's
always this with the padding yeah
eating and sleeping eating and sleeping
everybody looks dumb the first time like
like I fall asleep next to a guy I'm
just afraid of my dumb slovenly
expression really dumb dumb Fido does
not need a Gucci clip yeah what are we
doing holding one another at a concert
that's dumb
yeah yeah I always think no matter how
cool they may be you're like if you're
just like holding somebody it just looks
like it's that sound weird and yeah you
know what I don't respect you know it
always looks weird to me the tandem
bicycles
dumb you should never be that in love
yeah I don't think there's every time to
be
love the Japanese even on the bicycle
you can't be separated right you know
it's another thing I think you look
stupid doing if you're a guy and you're
wearing jeans with sandals what do you
wear to jeans with the sandals what are
you trendy Jesus what are you doing
I feel like if you wear sandals with
jeans you're either a billionaire or you
grow weed in the basement
[Applause]
[Music]
you